el 17 de febrero los libios conmemoran
lo que comenzó como una rebelión
pacífica en la ciudad de bengasi pero
que acabó convirtiéndose en un conflicto
armado con más de 8000 muertos y
desengaño entre la población
después de diez años las guerras
continúan y los políticos no nos
encomendaron la tarea no estaban a la
altura del conflicto escaló cuando la
otan bombardeó el país un mes después
del inicio de la revuelta los rebeldes
consiguieron tomar trípoli en agosto y
más tarde el 20 de octubre en sirte
capturaron a muammar al-gaddafi quien
fuese el dictador de libia durante 42
años fue en su ciudad natal y murió
asesinado junto a su hijo mutasem
me uní al levantamiento del 17 de
febrero de buena gana era mi deseo y mi
esperanza la de un joven graduado
desempleado y viviendo condiciones
difíciles
muchos confiaban en que la revuelta
mejoraría las condiciones básicas de
vida
diez años después libia todavía es un
estado fallido sumido en el caos y la
guerra civil una guerra en la que han
participado mercenarios extranjeros y
que ha sido víctima del pulso de
potencias internacionales sin embargo el
conflicto avanza hacia una solución al
que me han felicitó a todos los
involucrados en este proceso por su
valentía y determinación ahora es su
turno para dar forma al futuro del país
desde 2014 el país se dividió entre este
y oeste por un lado el gobierno de
acuerdo nacional reconocido por la onu y
establecida en trípoli y del otro lado
el ejército nacional libio de califa
haftar ubicado en bengasi este 2021 el 5
de febrero se llegó a un acuerdo entre
ambas partes para nombrar un consejo
presidencial y un jefe de gobierno que
supervisen las elecciones parlamentarias
y presidenciales previstas para
diciembre